Town of Salem is being turned
into a card game.
Check out the Kickstarter through the
link in the description below
and you can get EXCLUSIVE rewards
for backing it today.
This includes: Unlocked characters for the online game,
unlocked pets, and even a Not Safe for Work
expansion pack that won't be available
after the Kickstarter ends.
So check it out today.
Thanks for watching. ;)
[Spooky Voice] Have a lovely time.
Huhuahahaha
ouahaha
hoiaoioi
[Three Fabulous Chuckles]
HEH HEEH
[Laughter] We're so immature!
[More Laughing] Wade: Looks like SWEET BUTT
joined in.
Heheheheahahaa
Mark: Butt worked fine,
butt wasn't censored.
Jack: YEEAHH!!
And I put B-H-U-T-T...
Wade: HU HAHAA HA
Bob:hehehehehehaha
Mark: Oh man... Jack to Bob: you could change it to BOOT
BOOT
Oh, no! When you have three (3) it lowers the chances for the other ones.
Wade, Bob, Jack: (complaining noises)
Yeah!
I don't know how to play this! ^-^
Bob: Are you the arsonist?
Mark: Nah, I'm the witch
Bob: Oooh, fancy
Mark: What do I do with the witch? Jack: I'm a bodyguard, what do I do?
Bob: ♪ I will be your bodyguard ♪
Wade answering Jack: You pick someone to guard each night. If that person gets attacked, you die instead, but you kill the person who attacks
Mark: Are we still saying fire is super awesome?
All: yeah
(chuckles)
Wade: Someone's user is LordMinion777?
Mark: (Laughs)
(All laugh)
Mark: Oh man...
Bob: Hey, someone else has a fire house. This is bullshit.
Jack: I like how the glow at nighttime.
Bob: Ooh,  I gotta kill John Cena. I mean-- nothing
(Jack laughs)
Bob: We're on a team, right? We're all on a team?
Jack: Okay, I-I should protect some of you guys then.
Bob: K, you should keep me alive, I'm a serial killer (ends up into laughter)
Jack: Which-which one are you?
Bob: I'm SaltyLoveButtlet
Mark: I'm-wait, I'm Salty Love Butt, not Buttlet and I'm the witch.
But I don't know how to use the witch so I'm just gonna press random buttons and hope for the best.
Jack: O-o-hkay
Mark (with a mocking/joking tone): Okay
Jack: I wouldn't expect one different. Mark: (Chuckles)
Jack: Oh, no! Hod
Mark: Oh, no...
Wade: (sad elephant/trumpet noise)
Wade: That was my sad trumpet
Wade: Wait, why do I only see three (3) arsonist? Where's the fourth (4) arsonist?
Mark: I don't know, where do you see arsonists?
Wade: On the-
On the town. Someone picked the wrong...
Mark: (laughs)
Mark: Minx was an arsonist. Holy shit.
Jack: Salty Love Butt
Mark: Oh! I-.. I've got a-
I've got a different fire guy
Mine-.. I didn't know THAT guy was the fire guy
Bob: (laughing)
Mark: (giggles)
Jack: We killed an arsonist
Bob: The to-... the town is wrecking
Wade: THE ARSONIST DIED?!
(laughter)
Jack: Yo, bro, last night was straight FIRE
Mark: (giggles)
Jack: This place is LIT
(more laughter)
Mark: But, seriously, what do I do as witch?
I mean, it says I control someone..
(Wade explaining) You pick somebody and you have them target somebody else,
so the first one you pick is the person you're targetting-
-is the person you're controlling
The second one is who you're sending them after.
Mark: Okay... got it
Wade: so you can have, like, say that you found the Godfather
You could have the Godfather shoot somebody, shoot himself, shoot you..
If you find the doctor, you can force the doctor to heal you, like, you can do all kinds of stuff.
Mark: Okay
Bob: Just don't ever click any of us.
Wade: But you have to figure out what the roles are, cause some of them don't do anything.
So you might control someone make them do something else, but all they do is investigate them, for example.
Mark: Gotcha, okay. Well that's weird
(Bob mumbles something) Mark: Eeeh... eeeh...
Bob: Oh hey!
John Cena is immune
(OF COURSE)
Mark: John Cena is...
Bob: You shou- You should control John Cena
and try see if you can have him kill someone.
Mark: Oh, Okay!
Jack: And I- and I won't protect you.
Mark: I'll do mah BEEEEEEEST :D
Wade: I will as, uh, my role, I found John Cena claims to be escort.
Oooooooh... Bob: Sweet Butt is trying to be one of us >.>"
Should we allow them in the club? (Markimoo giggles)
Mark: Mmm... We... We'll decide later!
if he really has a sweet butt ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
We don't know...
Okay, so... Who did I... Who did I look at?
I-I've... I've tried to make Cave Johnson go after someone,
and then I tried to make... uuuuuuuuh...
(Mark draws a blank while others laugh)
I think Tormis- I think TormisSenpai I sent after someone, but I have no idea.
"Salty Butt Love-" (laughter) "is-" (Bob loses it)
Wait, wha-whu... What's NS? I don't know what that...
Bob: "Not Suspicious" Mark: Oh okay! Okay. Got it.
Wade: DIEDIEDIEDIEDIEDIEDIEDIEDIEDIE
Jack: Aww, they're one of us! :D
Mark: "An Amnesiac has remembered?" What does that mean?!
What is this?!
Wade: "Amnesiac" is someone who does- they get to pick a role from the graveyard.
(keyboard noises)
Wade: So, they could've picked sheriff, consigliere,
or Arsenist.
Mark: OOH! Yeah.
That's right.
Wade: So they kinda get to choose their role,
but they- it really depends on who dies as to what role they can end up with.
Mark: Uh-huh.
(Bob starts laughing)
Mark: Okay, so, we're pretty sure John Cena is the Godfather? (WHAT)
(Long silence)
Bob: Uh...
Wade: If they were immune night, it's because they were jailed.
Mark: Mhm.
(More silence)
Wait, when- I thought they were immune
the second night
Jack: Sweet Butt is whispering to Salty Love Buttlet.
(Markimoo laughter)
(Wade joins in)
Mark: Is that you, Bob? Trying to- trying to...
How do we do that?
Bob: I whispered them once, and they were like, "LEAVE ME ALONE!!"
(More Markimoo laughter)
Bob: I think we should all whisper Sweet Butt
sweet, sweet fiery things :D
Wade: How do we whisper?
Bob: / uh... /w space name
and then, your message.
Wade: So do you have to put space between "Sweet" and "Butt?"
Bob: Yeah. You have to type it like it is.
(Group giggle)
(All shit has been lost)
Mark: Oh man...
Jack: He's gonna be sooooo annoyed.
He's gonna kill himself. Bob: What did you guys say?
Wade: Oh, I forgot to- (Bob interrupts)
Jack: I didn't say anything.
Mark: Oh man...
Wade: I said "Hey~" :D (giggling)
Bob: Hey-ahahahaha
Alright, so Cave Johnson... Mark, was Cave Johnson useful?
Mark: No, he didn't do nothing
'cause I sent him- He's either, like, I sent him after John Cena,
and now I'm sending John Cena after Torm
because he's suspicious...
(Mark and Bob go "Hmhmm...")
Jack: Bob, what are you?
Bob: I'm a serial killer, babe ;)
Mark: Sewial Killa~ :3
Bob: Taking out all the Non-Butts
Wade: Yeah, take out the Non-Butts.
Mark: How did all of us have an Arsenist Scroll
and none of us got to be Arsenists?
(They notice that John Cena has left the game)
Mark: DAMMIT
I CONTROLLED HIM TOO HARD!!
His brain imploded :c
(all shit has been lost again)
OOH MAW GAWD 0_0
Jack: Yeah!
Wade: Wow.
(Bob still losing his shit)
Mark: Well
Bob: Oh my god
Mark: That... is-
Jack: TormisSenpai!
Mark: Oh geez!
Wade: (something) Mafia killed him.
(Lovely Markimoo laughter)
Ehh boy
Jack: He had nothing to give to his family :c
Mark: Oh geez
Wait, is that like a
Wade: WOAH 0_0"
Mark: Wait, is that a Dragon Ball Z, like, Super Saiyan pod or
or Saiyan... pod.. thing on the right there?
Jack: Yeah, I think so.
(Bob and Wade notice it)
Mark: Didn't even know that was a thing here
Nice
Cave Johnson-- Oh gawd...! Bob! You were the serial killer (giggling)
Bob: Maybe.. Mark: (laughing)
Jack: Do I spy a Wade?
Wade: Noo...?
Wade: Bwamuhaha
Oh hey Cave Johnson was the amnesiac (is that how u spell it?)
Jack in the background: (mumble mumble) fetish.
Bob: Aaa yeah, Mafia's.. last...
perso... last...
Mafia's...
Wade: So Mafia's got a
Mark and Jack: (laughing)
Bob: You know what I'm talking about!
Jack: Ma-mafia is last ma-mafia.... Maf'd.. Die- D-
We're winning! :D
Mark: (laughing)
Wade: You sayin' "maf dive?"
Jack: "I" has left the game? Mark: (still giggling)
Bob: (laughing)
Mark: Everyone's just leaving! Heh heh
Wade: Oh hey John Cena WAS an escort! Maybe he told the truth
Mark: WHAT?
They were escorts?!
Well, thats...
Bob: If people are gonna think, actually think, that Sweet Butt is like, on our tream..
Cuz we're all, like douchebags...
Mark: (laughing)
Mark: We should keep whispering to him over and over and then vote him off (laughing)
All: (laughing)
Jack: I was just going to say that xD
All: (still laughing)
Wade: Sweet Butt messaged me and said:
"YOU ARE DISGRACING ALL BUTTS"
Mark and Bob: (laughing)
Wade: And I replied: "Hey."
Mark: I'm asking him if his butt is strong enough
Jack and Bob: (laughing)
For the FIRE
(More wonderful Markimoo giggles)
Mark: Ohh man
Aww Cave Johnson left?
Noooooo~~!
Why'd Cave Johnson leave??
Oh he was dead, right?
Oh yeah, whatever.
Okay who should I make go after who?
Bob: Uhhh... I dunno
Jack: Make Sweet Butt go after people!
Mark and Jack: (laughing)
Mark: Sweet Butts going--
Sweet Butts going after Jonathan Corwin
Bob: Oh my god (laughter)
Mark: Go! Sweet Butt!
Our little (giggle) pet Sweet Butt!
Bob: (loses shit)
Jack: We're helping him! Mark and Bob: (still laughing)
Jack: You know what?
Just... aauhh
Just for that I'll protect him then..
Mark: Noo~!
Oh... Sweet Butt? Oh, okay
Well we don't know what Sweet Butt can do, butt...
hopefully it's something good..
Wade: You should protect ME, Jack!
Bob: OHNO
Mark: uH-OH
Wade: Uhoh
Bob: OHhh noo...
Mark: Oh...
Wade: Oh no...
Mark: NOOO~~!
Jack: And I was-- I was-- I was already protecting you, and then I changed it to Sweet Butt
Mark: Uoohh
Bob: Jack... Why you do these things
Jack: Well I would've died then!
Mark: Okay so I sent after Jonathan Corwin
which means Sweet Butt is the last member of the Mafia...
heh heh...
Jack: Oh shit why'd I protect him?
[Keyboard noises]
Jack: Bob, who did you go after?
Bob: I tried to kill.. uh... Luke Skywalker
And I was killed by a bodyguard..
Mark: Mh-hmm
Okay, so... I'm just going to send...
All: (talks all at once)
Mark: I'm gonna send Sweet Butt constantly
hehe
to other people
Oh no Sweet Butt's dead??
Bob: No, I'm dead
Wade: No, Sweet Butt's still alive
Mark: Okay gawd the naming was confusing me
ok
Wade: So I'm a little foreign here, beca--
Wade: Jack, should I--- should I kill
Sweet Butt?
Mark: Noo!
Bob: No, just let Mark control Sweet Butt
Mark: Yeah I'll-- I'll get him to kill all our enemies
All: (talks all at once)
Wade: --I'm town!
Mark: Theres only two left!
Bob: Yeah, I know!
Jack: Who cares?
Bob: Use Sweet Butt to kill everyone else, and then vote Sweet Butt up
Jack: Hehehehe
Wade: O-kay
Jack: We need to kill Luke Skywalker and Rey!
Mark: Mh-hm.
Okay.
I'll send our little pet Sweet Butt,
Our little sweetie buddy
(giggling)
after Rey
Rey, and then Luke Skywalker
who they are probably working together
because of STARWARS!
And we need to get them outta here.
Wade: (laughing)
Bob: (laughing)
Wade: Because of STAR WARS!
(laughing)
Wade: They're probably working together
because of STAR WARS!
Jack: That'll work in court.
Bob: Ahahahaha
Wade: You see, they're probably working together, because of STAR WARS!
Bob: --the Star Wars defence, right, right
Mark: No! Cause you know... Rey..?
in the new Star Wars
its not a spoiler
Jack: Oh we get it! We get it
Mark: Yeah, its Rey! Her ne-- ru-- Luke!
at the end they were staring.. you know!
Bob: (laughing)
Mark: Doing the thing?
Bob: What did Sweet Butt say?
Mark: He didn't say anything
Bob: (laughing)
Wade: Why are they whispering thi--
I think they're replying to the wrong Butt!
Mark: (laughing)
Jack: Its hard. Its hard.
Bob: They don't even know which Butt
They're talkin' to all the Butts
Mark: Uhh so many Butts.. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Wade: They said "WHO ARE YOU"
So I said "Hey."
Mark: They said who are you back
Bob: (laughing in the background)
Bob and Wade: (laughing)
Jack: No! You ca-- You can't vote against us!
Wade: THESE BUTTS ARE INSANE!
(Shit has been lost once more)
Mark: Allright, so Sweet Butts going after Rey!
Mark and Bob: (laughing)
Wade: And then we're gonna hang Luke Skywalker?
Mark: Yeah!
Jack: No! No, Bob should go after Luke Skywalker!
Bob: I'm dead, maaaan
Wade: Bob was the Salty Love Buffet (WHAT)
Or no... Bu.. bu.. buttlet..
Mark: (laughing) Salty Love Buffet..?
Jack: Luke Skywalker left!
Mark: Oh well
It's one less we have to kill!
Bob: --you can do it
Mark: Oh man
Goood shit.
Wade: So wait, who's the Godfather?
Mark: Oh yeah-- oh-- wait
I-- I'm guessing Sweet Butt
yea, Sweet Butt. Yep! There he goes
Yup! Rey's dead!
Wade: So are we hanging Sweet Butt then?
Mark: YEAH, YEAH WE ARE
All: (laughing)
Mark: (laughing)
Bob: Ohh perfectly orchestrated victory..
Girlfriend wants you dead? Jesus.
Mark: Huhuh
Wade: WOW!
They don't get along very well
Jack: I don't even know her
Wade (?): Sad trumpet noises
Mark: Wait, so.. oh yeah thats right
the amnesiac remembered that he was a ser---
uh...
Mafia, so that means Sweet Butt must have been the amnesiac
Jack: Ohh yeah, I just remembered I love killing people
[Keyboard noises]
Wade: Cave Johnson was the anmesiac
because he became the consigliere
so yeah, Sweet Butts gotta be the Godfather
Bob: (chuckling)
Bob: These Butts are on fire~~
Wade: So we're hanging Sweet Butt right?
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Butts are on fiiiaaaaarrrre~~
Wade: Ok, so which one is.. Who are you all?
Which one are you, Mark?
Mark: I'm Salty Love Butt.
Jack: I'm BOOT
Mark: BOOT! BOOT LOVE SALT!
TRUNK! TRUNK LOVE SALT! (not sure what he's saying here)
Mark: (laughing)
Jack: Trunk love!
Mark: (laughing) Butts! What the fuck!
Bob: Sweet Butt has just.. been upon us this whole--
Mark: (laughing)
Bob: (laughing)
Alright, now don't forget to vote, everybody
(How many times are these goofs gonna lose their shit?!)
Mark: We didn't forget, Bob!
We would never forget..
Bob: I-- I frequently forget to vote.
Mark: (laughing)
Wade: (laughing)
Mark: Ohh my godd...
Jack: --Now we get a chance to be a dick
Mark: God that was perfect
Bob: If only I haven't died! Why!
Mark: I know, yeah
Bob: --Why didn't you save me--
Wade and Jack: WITCH I HATE YOU!
Mark: (laughing)
Bob: (laughing)
Mark: Oh man. Wait, so what are you guys left? What are you
Okay, Wade was Town, right? You're jailor
Wade: I'm jailor
Mark: And..
Jack: Bodyguard.
Mark: You're bodyguard. So--
Wade: I've already jailed you tonight, Mark, you're gone
Mark: Yeah, ok, kill me. I was about to say, kill me,
you guys win.. I was... I-- I can't win!
Wa-- do-- don-- I can't win!
How am I gonna win?
Bob: Mark, there is a way that you could win..
Mark: Is there?
Wade: I don't know if there is, because he'd have to-- it'd be one on one
Mark: Hmm.
Wade: Unless he had me...
Jail murder myself
I don't know if thats possible
Mark: I don't think thats possible...
Jack: Awwww noo the robot's crying spahrks
Bob: Thats how physics.
Mark: (laughing) Jack: WHERE IS THE BUTT LOVE?
Bob: Oh, you just got the Butt Love ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Mark: Hehehe
Bob: That was it
Mark: Oh well
Jack: Butt Buddyyyy!!
Yay!
Mark: Oh, there we go! Yaaaaaaaaay!
Wade: Yay!
Mark: Good end! We didn't have to kill each other! Horray!
Hahahahhaha
Okay
Jack: --Power the button, man
Mark: Well done, everybody